you're wri in the book which everybody
should get it's a great book it's a
great read it's a window into your soul
you uh in this book write that there's
five kinds of infidelity do you remember
can you explain um yeah I mean what I
wanted to say is that all infidelity is
not the same that there's different
kinds and some of them are more obvious
than others like there's the the
soulmate you
know that's the one I think I most often
which is a person meets another person
or
rekindles on social media or elsewhere a
reconnection with another person in
their life and they go oh my God this is
the person I'm supposed to be with I'm
in love the heart wants what the heart
wants like I'm I'm leaving you for this
person because I have found my true love
that's one type and it's an incredibly
common
type and there's a you know there are
plenty of cautionary tales associ iated
with that where people thought that they
found their someone and then it turns
out it was you know no it was just an
affair you know um and and and you know
a man who leaves his wife for his
mistress just leaves a new job
opportunity open you and we should also
mention that you uh you know talk about
Facebook and Instagram oh yes if we were
going to invent an infidelity generating
machine it would be called Facebook
which by the way is a function of the
fact the book was written in 2019 I
would now change it to Instagram oh cuz
he said just Facebook yes but now if I
had to rewrite it it would be if we were
going to invent an infidelity generating
machine it would be called meta that
would be what yeah there you go yeah
very Tech forward it's a was a function
of what Facebook and I think Instagram
also are which is it is a communication
tool that has people looking into
windows that I think are antagonistic to
marriage you're looking into the lives
of other people you're looking into um
the social lives of of people that you
meet casually so there was a time where
you would be at your son's soccer
practice and see the attractive mom
across the way and you wouldn't really
talk to her interact with her if you did
it would just be at
practice but now we add on social media
those people because for legitimate
reasons we need to maybe communicate
about when practices or we want to
message the person but now it's sort of
an invitation to a connection and then
it's you know there's a picture of her
on vacation in a bikini that's very
intriguing and then you have a benign oh
I saw you guys went on vacation where
did you stay you know oh was it good did
you like that oh that's nice and now
we're talking and now we're having an
interaction and now this is how the
spark of Affairs begins it's usually
people don't usually meet and go would
you like to potentially wreck your
marriage yes would you oh my god let's
do this like it's much more you know
it's slowly happen so when I talk about
types of
infidelity the soulmate the unexpected
soulmate you know this connection that
you didn't expect I didn't expect to
fall in love with this person but I did
and the heart wants what the heart wants
and I'm
sorry that one's tough that one's tough
because you know it's an interesting
distinction between men and women to
some degree that when a man finds out
his wife was cheating the question is
did you him and when a woman finds
out that a man cheated the question is
do you love her
you know and those are those are
different things you know I feel like
there could be many and have been many
books written on that yeah there have
been by much smarter people than me yeah
but but um I I think
that the soulmate thing is very very
painful for a lot of my female clients
when a man says listen I found the one I
found the one and it's not you um that
that is really really hard hard to get
past
um even when it turned out to be true I
mean I've seen some people that you know
it was an affair that turned into 20
plus year marriages you know so I I an
unhappy marriage and then a happy Affair
that turned into a very happy marriage
like I don't I've not seen there's not a
formula you know like I've I've been
doing it long enough now that I've seen
permutations I never would have expected
um so that's one type of infidelity um
the other is what I call the push out of
the closet which is is and that I think
happened more often earlier in my career
there have been tremendous strides I
think in in the the the lesbian and gay
community um where including marriage
equality obviously where there's a lot
of change as to people accepting people
as being gay or lesbian um and I think
that there was a time where you know
people were having being in the closet
was much more important you were subject
to professional scorn and you know all
kinds of things if you were gay or
lesbian so people were sneaking around
and having affairs with their same-sex
partners and then they get caught and
then you know it really was a function
of the of the of the um the fact that
they were closeted um and again that's
another kind of complicated dynamic
because you know I I I haven't had that
happen to me where a woman left me for a
woman MH but I'd like to think it would
be
easier for me yeah because if you left
me for a man you're saying I want one
like you but better than you whereas if
you leave me for a
woman well that's a whole different set
of equipment I don't have that yeah so
like I can't like okay like it's not me
it's you it's something you want that I
can't offer it's I don't we don't serve
that at this restaurant so you know it's
okay like yeah I get it I mean there's a
betrayal there's a sadness whatever but
yeah you know it's a different thing um
the the
saddest type of infidelity in my opinion
is the mistake which is someone just
makes a mistake they they they just
people do dumb when it comes to sex
like people just in a
moment you know they sub they follow
Temptation their impulse control is poor
you know and they they do something that
they that doesn't reflect their morality
or doesn't reflect the depth of their
feelings like have you spent enough time
in a room with people who've cheated in
a relationship and are speaking candidly
to you about it because you're their
lawyer they they'll say to you very
openly like no I really love my wife I
really love my wife like I just I don't
know I was just an idiot like I just you
know I saw this bright shiny object and
I went for it I I really wanted to sleep
with that woman like I I wanted to I
wanted to her I love my wife I make
love to my wife I love my wife but I
just want to sleep with this one you
know and we created a culture where one
of those eradicates the other I I don't
that's a whole another discussion is you
know is there ethical non- monogamy like
should we is
marriage about who I have sex with or is
marriage a different kind of a
partnership is it a is it a pair bond
that's about building a life together
you know and where does monogamy fit
into that and people like Ester Perell
and they those are people who are making
very intelligent discussions about that
you know yeah that's a complicated one
just to actually just Linger on that
have you how often have people with open
marriages have been in your office well
let's see and this is one of those like
from a research perspective this would
be flawed because I see the
they're in my office CU their marriage
is falling apart so there may be lots of
people having open relationships that
don't end up in a divorce lawyer office
so I'd never meet them but I meet a lot
of people that that was the Hail Mary
pass sure like I meet a lot of people
that they tried that but it in
retrospect it was a Hail Mary pass it
was like a look we' just figured let's
try this you like maybe it's maybe this
will this will keep the glue together on
this thing you know and and um and I've
also seen open open relationships go
wrong you know where we agree we're just
going to have sexual connections with
other people or we're going to bring
other people into the
bedroom um but together like we're going
to be together with other people or with
another person and then the the
connection of those two
people like you you think it's a
soulmate all of a sudden now and it goes
in this other because and again is that
novelty is that like it's the reason why
I don't understand why people have thre
it's kind of like you know when someone
sings to you I don't know where to look
like I don't know where to look like if
someone's singing to me I don't know
where to look like it feels weird right
like this is a conundrum my this no
this I'll say this too this will never
but I it's the reason I can't go to
strip clubs yeah I don't know where to
look like if I go to strip club you know
like you go to strip club and and there
there's you know the part where they the
woman's on the stage and she walks past
each person does a little thing and then
next person and then next little thing
so when she's right in front of
you I like a woman's face and I like a
woman's body I like both of them so I'm
looking at the woman's face and she's
very beautiful but she's naked and I
think oh she's naked I should be looking
at her naked body because obviously
that's like it's almost rude not to
because she's naked in front of me of
course so then I'm looking at her naked
body which is lovely to look at but then
I find myself going oh my God you're
just still like you should look at her
face for God's sake and then I'm looking
at her face and and find myself having
this whole thing in my head where I'm
going like oh my God where am I supposed
to look so I think a threesome with two
women you don't hardly know or you're
not that's different but a threesome
with a long-term partner who you're in a
relationship with and a new
person seems to me a very dangerous
ground because you're going to want to
enjoy the novelty of this new person but
you're going to have to spend time with
this person after so how much attention
do you spend to the new novel exciting
thing without creating the impression
that you don't you're not interested in
this because you want you're my favorite
person but this is fun so I want to just
try this for a few but then also I don't
want to forget about that like it it
just seems tricky that analogy by the
way is brilliant and also I guess it's
tricky because the consequences of
mistakes are quite High because you're
going to have to talk about it right and
there's a there's an easy way to
misinterpret the data right like so if
I'm if I really like sleeping with my
partner but I get one chance to sleep
with this other person like well of
course I should indulge in that because
I can do this anytime like what you know
but but this person my partner might
interpret that as oh so you're more
interested in her than me because that
voice in in my partner that would be you
know insecure might hear that you know
so I I just why would you even why would
you open yourself up to that level of
chaos you seem to love chess in the
courtroom it's a kind of uh intimate
human chess of sorts yeah no that's
that's too high risk how do we get on
threes Sims oh open open marriages well
we got we get on threes SS I don't know
I always wonder how people get on threes
Sims um I figure they like if one is fun
two must be better if two is better
three must be better um yeah I I think
we we the way that that this becomes an
issue
is why would you have a non- monogamous
relationship what is it about your sex
life with this person that's not
satisfying and I think that that is the
question that's harder to ask yourself
and to try to answer with your
partner